and you're you're in uh
the insurance business i am how did you
get into that
world you first started okay got it yeah
so i got into a insurance world
uh when i got out of the military i went
to i wanted to be bodybuilders so
originally that was going to be route i
was going to take and then i met a girl
who worked at morgan stanley dean with a
long story short i started working on
morgan's standing dean wither a day
before 9 11.
and then got my series 7 66 21 you know
26 all the licenses
at 21 years old and fell in love with
the industry i said this is what i'm
going to do so i left
morgan i went to transamerica i became
an insurance agent for the next seven
and a half years
and then october 09 started my own
company php with 66
agents and today we have somewhere
around 17 to 18 000 insurance agents in
49 states
wow what kind of insurance do you sell
life and annuities it's a it's a
life any kind of life and then annuities
for retirement
man i don't have a very good experience
with insurance companies i'm not gonna
lie to you i have a pretty
pretty bad uh experience with them i had
uh i had business insurance
and you know from my experience
insurance companies only try to do two
things sell you the policy and then get
out of
whatever claims that you have i don't
think you're wrong when it comes down to
pnc
that's pnc it's a completely different
model what does pnc mean
property and casualty you're talking
about property insurance you're not
talking about life insurance
right no yeah i'm talking about
specifically actually it was a
professional insurance something like
that
the reason why there are so many unhappy
people like you and i about pnc is
because there's so many
so many uh of words their attorneys use
to give them an out
yeah but on life if you have a death
certificate
there is no words you're dead okay it's
very simple so if you buy if you buy a
million dollar policy
and you die and you get into a car
accident you die you send the death
certificate we're sending you a million
auto check even if you just pay 30 bucks
on the term policy
wow interesting wow that's a completely
different world than what i'm
what i'm used to night and day it's not
not even this time it's completely night
and day
that's pretty cool man that's really
cool so how did you transition from
insurance
insurance world to something like this
to making videos and doing interviews
and
you do a lot of cool stuff yeah purely
accidental you know one day i was
creating content
on the backend so you couldn't see the
content we were creating for the company
and one of my guys came and said pat why
don't you create content for public
and i said i don't really know if
there's going to be a public need for
what we're doing he said just try it out
i said okay let's make a couple videos
we made a couple videos
i said if i do it i'm going to commit to
two years so i did one video a week it
was called two minutes with pat
two years later you know there was some
interest we had a few thousand subs and
i said okay let's try to do a little bit
more
and then we went to 40 000 subs and then
i changed the channel's name from my
name to valuetainment
and then from valuetainment it grew from
40 000 subs to i don't know what we have
right now but 2.5 2.6 million subs and
uh
we interview a lot of different
characters you know whether it's a kobe
bryant the late kobe bryant to a cuban
to a
uh uh sammy to be garvano to a
uh a political figure president bush to
magic johnson to wayne gretzky a lot of
different people we
interview and it turned into what it is
today so it was purely accidental now
it's a media company now we have a new
site
now we have valuetainment russian with
170 000 subs now we're doing vitamin
arabic
spanish portuguese by timon money
vitamin economics vitamin politics
we just started a podcast we got a new
site called vtpost.com that we launched
i think three four weeks ago
so now it's becoming a media company and
that'll be kind of what i'll do after uh
uh i replace myself here with the
insurance company
replace yourself with the insurance
company what do you mean by you mean
you're going to put somebody in your
play are you going to sell it or what
are you going to do
you replace so i hired another ceo to
run this company oh you're still going
to own the company
until somebody buys it i was still on
the company okay cool
on the description of your channel
valuetainment
it says the the best channel for
entrepreneurs what does that mean and
how did you
did you have that in mind when you when
you started it or
is that just kind of how it evolved
naturally
no it was actually originally i mean it
was all entrepreneur every content we
put up
it was only entrepreneur every content
was only entrepreneur so if you go on
youtube
you go to filters you type an
entrepreneur and you go filters views
valuetainment pops up as a number one
channel
uh for the most views so that's the
valuetainment part but at beginning at
the beginning it was purely business
how to raise money how to hire how to
fire how to recruit
how to bring a business partner how do
you negotiate with a multi-billion
dollar company how do you go out there
and
uh uh different ways of uh raising money
how do you deal with
angel investors how to send that email
to angel investors you know how do you
deal with bankruptcy how do you manage
running the company and uh
being married and having kids so
everything we ever did
for valuetainment up until uh 2018 was
100 entrepreneurship in 2018 i did one
interview with michael francis the
mobster
and from there all of a sudden everybody
else started showing up hey how about we
do this how about we do this interview
and all of a sudden we did bodybuilding
interviews on bodybuilding interviews
we got 15 20 million views on mob
interviews
uh we got 30 40 50 million views on
you know then it became niches then
china took off and the topic of iran
took off then the topic of
capitalism took off so then it becomes
topics probably kind of like your own
channel that you have
who's your biggest hit you've ever had
on your channel give me the
the one topic that's done the best on
your channel
uh i think it's this kid who plays
fortnite for a living
okay so so go gamers that's one right
what is another topic
uh the other most popular one was about
a guy who bought a five million dollar
lamborghini in south beach
so if i go to concrete channel
you will kind of see even your own
channel that you have
a gamer 4.2 million views now are you a
big gamer yourself
no but i'm good i mean just a friend of
mine i thought it was interesting
but i mean it looks like phenomenal 4.2
million views that's a that's a great
interview right so next you got
a guy buys a lamborghini for four
million dollars okay that's the second
one third one is a pirate junkie
fourth one is uh he looks familiar he's
a uk guy what's uh
he's a oh he's the ecstasy guy you got
the four but you got michael
uh uh who what is matthew cox right okay
so for you
you got gamers you got cars lifestyle
you got pirate junkie which is random
you got drugs you got
con you got real estate you got a real
estate guy there
so those are your six that you're
pulling from i would probably be doing
more gaming if i'm you because you got
an audience of gaming so
when you start doing shows they become
hit and miss like we started doing vlogs
when we did vlogs uh i got to tell you
my vlogs
are probably the worst vlogs you'll ever
see on youtube
why is that if you go look at my vlogs
it's
you know it's there's nothing crazy
about the vlogs why
why is there nothing crazy about my
vlogs i don't have the most interesting
life to the average person to say i
can't wait to see what this guy does
like i don't have time to go out there
and say
you know let's go get uh uh
16 cases of skittles take throw it in a
bathtub and get two girls
who are willing to jump in here and
let's throw nutella on top of it get 17
million views i don't have that kind of
time right so
some people who do vlogs they're very
interesting and they know how to keep
attention a lot for vlogs like
the logan paul's or the jake paul's or
something they're killing it with vlogs
but then the vloggers sometimes try to
do what you're doing
that doesn't work for them sometimes the
the content creators which are the
how-to business guys
try to do things others are doing it
doesn't work for them sometimes the
motivational guys go into interviews
their interviews don't work obviously
you're a good interviewer if you got
seven eight interviewers over a million
views you obviously are good at
interviewing people but that's not
everybody not everybody is good at
interviewing people so it's not
uh uh uh it's not something that uh
works for everybody like
i don't know if you've tested doing
vlogs or not on your own life have you
done vlogs
before no i'm not interested in doing
any of that stuff
that's that's a that's an interesting
idea that you just mentioned how you
said
because i have a video that has 4
million views about a gamer
maybe i should do more gaming stuff
it may have an audience for it